two exes reunite while one dancer brings
the ballroom to tears we've got the four
must-see moments from the Dancing with
the Stars premiere Bruce Willis and Demi
Moore showed up to the season 20
premiere to support daughter rumor who
closed out the show with her partner Val
Chmerkovskiy but the former couple did
not sit together Bruce at front row with
wife Emma while Demi sat a few rows
behind our 5s Riker Lynch was a big
surprise of the night he delivered an
energized performance to what I like
about you with partner Allison Holker
and Bruno was clearly impressed
you're tiny is you not killer I can't
wait to see you do the next time next
week brilliant Patti LaBelle's Foxtrot 2
Lady Marmalade brought the audience to
their feet and the legendary singer even
got emotional on the dance floor when
the judges dished their feedback you can
see the grace of his beautiful woman
from the hands the fingers a little
shuck tick tick tick tick do they but it
was double amputee and combat veteran
Noah Galloway's inspirational
performance that had the room in tears
his kids cheering and even made judge
Carrie Ann Inaba speechless Oh emotional
okay
it was profound and you're broadening my
scope of what dance looks like and bonus
moment Suzanne Somers brought back the
ThighMaster